there is no such thing as failure  failure is just life trying to move us  in another direction when you're down in  the hole when that moment comes it's  really okay to feel bad for a little  while give yourself time to mourn what  you think you may have lost but then  here's the key learn from every mistake  because every experience encounter are  there to cheat you and force you into  being more of who you are there is I  know this there's a light inside each of  you that illuminates your very human  being miss if you let it and as a young  girl from rural Mississippi I learned  long ago that being myself was much  easier than pretending to be Barbara  Walters I figured out oh gee I can be a  much better Oprah than I could be a  pretend Barbara don't ask yourself what  the world needs ask yourself what makes  you come alive and then go do that  because what the world needs is people  who have come alive  you